[ __ ]
well and a lot of girls don't realize
that the nagging is so deep like that's
men men love through respect right and
when you're just like that's how they
feel love and when you're disrespecting
a man that's that's saying you don't
love him basically
yes literally
a woman can't love a man she doesn't
respect and it it's it's weird because
when men and women are seeing their
wedding vows or when they're committing
to each other whatever the case may be
there are back in the day
just about every woman fully intended on
going through with their wedding vows
but these days it could not be more
different it's really just kind of lip
service just to kind of say what you
want to say and now we have people
rewriting their vows and and the uh
whoever is in charge of the uh of the
wedding
he sits there for 10 minutes and talks
about everything that the man needs to
do for her
that the husband needs to do for the
wife but then when it comes to the
wife's responsibility
now it's crickets that's that's just how
it is these days well and that's why you
see everyone asking women what they
bring to the table and it's crickets
yeah right right
it's interesting what the the question
what do you bring to the table should be
extended
what can you offer me
that you have never given to another man
most women can't most women can't answer
that question because most women have
given their bodies to men they've given
them their time they've given them
children they've given they've given all
of these other men all of these things
but then they expect a man to give them
everything that we have to offer i think
we heard this on the sauce cast um it's
um it's meat it's uh what is it money
energy attention and time when
women expect all of this money uh energy
attention and time for for what what for
them just being there
no no no you've given what what you are
offering to me is something that you've
given to 474 other dudes no i need to
know what you bring i need to go 474
dude i'm trying to tell you
420.
it might have been for it might have
been
403 listen whatever the case may be
there are some triple and quadruple
digit hoes out here running these
streets and we will never listen you
will never know what help most women
probably don't even know what their body
counts are but the point is is that dude
99 of women out there don't bring
anything to the table that they haven't
brought to the table and every other
relationship which is pta and i'm not
talking about the parent teachers yeah i
mean this is where um uh this is where
uh being average at best comes to your
advantage because you've gotta like have
some utility you got to bring something
useful to the table because it ain't
looks you know
well and and that's well this is this is
what this is what that what this is what
devin's talking about devon's the most
attractive woman i've ever committed to
she's certainly the most useful i've had
some listen man i've been with dated
slept with some extremely attractive
women uh in my day and listen some of
them i like some of them i thought i
loved but in the end
good-looking women
are useless because they've never really
had to be useful especially in this day
and age most sevens eights nines and
tens are monetized or sponsored in some
type of way that's not a slight on them
that's just the world we live in well as
an attractive woman if you are given the
world simply because of the way you look
what motivation is there to develop
yourself outside of the way that you
look as a result we have some extremely
uh hollow vapid good-looking women out
here who don't really bring much to the
table except for good looks and drama
and a lot of guys a lot of guys would
kill for good looks and drama for a
little while but as a man who has had a
lot of experience with a lot of
beautiful women and i'm glad that i'm
glad i had that experience i wouldn't
trade it for the world and i would never
say well i would never no i'm glad that
i [ __ ] a bunch of hot [ __ ] by the
same token the the more the the you
quickly sort of figure out that the more
attractive a woman is the less useful
they tend to be um and people can say oh
well that's your excuse listen man um
say whatever you want i'm i'm happy in
my relationship i tell guys all the time
if you're looking for if you're looking
for a long-term relationship or someone
to commit to
dudes eights nine dudes sevens eights
nines and tens belong to the game man
look look in the five to six range um
look for a girl who's who's in the five
to six range who becomes maybe a seven
or an eight behind closed doors
so question what
devin what was your biggest challenge
when i'm assuming your past
relationships may have been more modern
is that true or false
may have been more what modern
i'm assuming this is the most
traditional relationship you've been and
i can't imagine like
i mean yeah if you want to put a label
on it yeah i mean my my previous
relationship where i was married for
15 we were together almost 20 years
so
you know i didn't i didn't know that
there was like
a way to do this you know i thought the
way that they teach you is the way that
it goes and
you know you go through life and and you
you you know you don't cheat and you
try to make it work right and it's a
little bit more complicated than that um
i think that people overlook the
importance of respect in a relationship
because i don't think that women are
capable of loving a man that they do not
respect
and
women actually lose respect for their
men
by the way that they treat them
so finding a man who won't put up with
any of the nonsense won't put up with
the wrong tone of voice won't put up
with you know me being disrespectful in
any way
forces me into the position where i say
okay you know
uh that's not you know that doesn't fly
that doesn't become a habit and you know
we
we we're consistent with one another
um a lot of people don't have
consistency in their relationships
they're oh no they're what girl the girl
is
as sweet one day and she said she's a
total you know what the next day
and
you know the
the man just takes it
so
good
so i was just curious it was there a
learning curve when you first yeah yeah
that's that's what i was curious about
yeah i had a lot of bad habits that that
had to be
almost literally like trained out of me
it was like you know you know similar to
the things like i said like tone of
voice but even something like as simple
as when we're in the car and he's
driving
and
you know it's the you know to say okay
hey we need to turn left here or like no
no backstage driver you know yeah like
trying to you know
trying to be just being an annoying
passenger basically you know
any time
like for example
donovan loves to leave like all of the
cabinet doors open whenever he goes in
the kitchen like everything's open like
the microwave's open the freezer i'll do
that too
yeah
what do you want yeah nobody's going and
instead of me you know the old me would
have been like
god you're so lazy like you just closed
or like to make a make a point i'll slam
them shut or something oh hell no or you
know like god do you mind like what's
wrong with you now i'm just like you
know what let's let let's take a step
back and think about the grand scheme of
things okay
um
he provides
he protects
he you know he makes me laugh like we
have we have a great life together if
if all it takes is for me to close a
couple cabinet doors every now and then
maybe i should just shut my mouth and do
it
uh we need to really pick our battles
and a lot of women don't know how to to
do that um small potatoes are small
potatoes these are things that you got
to learn to live with and you you know
like
the small things that people do that
like women just oh my god i can't stand
he leaves a toilet seat up my god that's
a deal breaker oh my god you know like
hey you're going to be alone for a very
long time if you don't learn how to live
with somebody and i think a lot of
people don't know how to
um how to uh moderate what they're
willing to accept
some women just end up accepting things
that are extremely bad and won't accept
a toilet seat up but they'll accept you
know him being an alcoholic yeah
something like that so
yeah
women have a little it's a little
convoluted well it's convoluted because
women
women are under the impression the
reason why women are so picky and
selective and women have to be the more
selective gender this is just how it is
there are biological reasons involved
i'm not going to get into that but women
have become so selective
that they it's almost like they take
themselves off the market they are so
inundated with option with what they
perceive to be long-term options day in
day out that they disqualify men for the
most idiosyncratic things just like just
like dev just said leaving the the the
toilet seat up dude in all the years
i've ever known deb i leave the toilet
seat up all the time she has never ever
ever said anything about it i leave
cabinets open all the time she doesn't
she never has bitched and moaned about
it and the reason for that is because
the life that i provide for her makes
those things
menial it doesn't it doesn't really
matter
but but women are always so picky and
they disqualify men for the smallest of
uh the smallest of infractions only
because they think they've got a line of
men
waiting to make their acquaintance while
that may be true these men are
interested only in short-term uh
short-term relationships in other words
they're only really after them for sex
and the men that want them for more than
just sex are not the men they want
unfortunately for women they don't
figure this out until they're in their
mid to late 30s and they've been dumped
for the third time in three days
[Music]